there's your top coat
The Prince and the president AS Global
greetings go they don't come much bigger
than this they've met before but perhaps
now more than ever Prince William needs
this welcome
um
on the final day of the trip a tour of
the John F Kennedy Library led by the
late president's daughter
JFK's moonshot the inspiration for
Williams earthshot prize
and for Kate it was back to school
making her Mark at Harvard
and meeting the University's early years
experts
she came for the science
they came to meet a princess I'm
focusing on what the causes that they're
here for this week which I think is just
so important for our children for our
future and the universities and schools
that focus on you know protecting our
climate and protecting our Earth I think
are so important with over ISRO I feel
like they handled it perfectly
um and I think obviously there's
probably some learnings that are coming
out of it they've done a wonderful job
kind of modernizing themselves but
keeping true to tradition and what it
has stood for over the
over time and so to earthshot Prince
William's prize moment his environmental
Awards and a star-studded reason for the
visit
we believe that this is the earthshot
decade and we collectively need to
figure out how we're going to repair and
regenerate the planet in as fast as as
possible a manner as we can the
Ingenuity that is being discovered by an
award like earthshot is second to none
and when you have a million pounds going
to people who can
indelibly affect the world we live in
and and the world that future
Generations will hopefully live in is
profound
phrase some
some how do they present themselves as a
modern monarchy and how long can they
say nothing about the Family Feud that's
playing out so publicly
The Prince and Princess of Wales just
hoping for a positive end to this
challenging trip Laura bundock Sky News
in Boston